i'm excited to let you uh hear this
i will be in savannah georgia june 2nd
i'm coming this week
augusta georgia june 3rd
montgomery alabama june 4th and over to
columbus georgia june 5th i'm very
excited to be there and see you guys
as well
hollywood florida fort myers florida
daytona beach
and lakeland florida that's june 23rd
through june 26th tickets on sale now at
theovonn.com
t-o-u-r
don't go through a different vendor
go through
the theovon site so that you can get
them
uh
correct because otherwise these people
jack them up and they jack you
over today's guest is um well we're not
going to go too much into his history
when he and i talk
because most you should know him you and
if you don't know him i'll just tell you
now he's from impractical jokers the
television program heading into its 10
number 9 or 10 season
and they've just um
i mean it's a it's an american staple it
really is if you if you
don't like it your cousin does or your
grandmother does
and um
he's part of that group him and three of
his friends and um
he's a buddy of mine i almost went on
his cruise a few i did go on his cruise
shoot i just remembered and forgot i
went on as impractical joker's cruise a
few years ago
uh he has two podcasts one called hey
babe with chris de stefano and another
one called taste buds with joe derosa
i couldn't be happier to sit down with
anyone ladies and gentlemen mr sal
volcano
[Music]
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trying to get better man been leaning
back into my sobriety program so that's
been helping me okay and how how's it
going
it's good it's starting to feel good
it's just taking a while where do you
where do you do that you know
um here in l.a are you oh yeah are you
back are you you here now are you still
i'm back and forth okay so yeah i got me
a house split it uh yeah i would say
it's probably split yeah you got to go
there like 51 like 183 you gotta legally
be there it's almost like
having to be in that in two places it's
almost like whenever you see that
baseball player and he has his foot on
the back yeah like waiting to steal yeah
you start to lead and then and then the
irs kind of checks the bag
dude that's exactly what it's like
so
it's definitely like relaxing there
people are so friendly i get to have
like a whole new walk of like so like
socialize and immediately people
feel what it's like to be in a smaller
environment
um your move there was your first move
there right like you weren't that you
weren't familiar with it but friday no i
didn't know it's kind of i can't even
believe i did it i i mean i know i
wanted to save tax money and then
i always wanted to live there
so it seems like a dope spot i love it
every time i go yeah it's fun it's it's
just you know it's not la or new york so
it's just it's just smaller yeah yeah
are you limited though
with
being able to to work out and do spots
and stuff like that um
oh yeah right because you got zany's
that's it
and there's no likes produced there's no
there's no like bar or produce shows or
anything like that at all there may uh i
don't think there's a big scene so it's
just zany's yeah so when you're there
for like weeks at a time are you just
going to zany's every night and just
popping in you can't really do that so
you can kind of go
they have an open mic night or i'll do
my own night okay um but it's like kind
of yeah it's uh
that's the tough part is keeping the
comedy going right during the pandemic
it didn't matter because a lot of places
weren't open anyway right so but this
keeps you probably sharp especially the
one that you do when you just do it
yourself
yeah that i think that helps i i mean
for me really comedy i got to be on
stage yeah yeah
um
i got to be i i learn about this
repetition yep yeah like some people the
more they write the stuff and if it's a
good but i gotta be up there feeling it
yeah you write stuff down or no ever um
yeah sometimes yeah if i get my friends
to laugh sometimes yeah yeah you know
i'll write out like the
like the big beats but like then if i
haven't done what i'll do is if i
haven't done the pandemic i went back
and transcribed everything yeah
because it was just easier to get back
into it after that long you know so i
was like i have a reference point
anytime i blank because i was getting
back up and missing whole chunks oh
that's the worst yeah so yeah the worst
is like the other night i did a show and
i got to the end of the show and i
almost wanted to run back out there
because i forgot to do one of the best
bits
[Laughter]
so i want to apologize i think that was
i think that was in midland texas man i
owe you guys a good joke
um
but yeah is it hard to separate like uh
do you find a tough time like doing
stuff for your show and then like
getting into a different brain for
comedy or not really nah i haven't
compartmentalized you know but what
what's kind of gets tricky is like when
i'm on a tour with the guys and like i'm
doing my tour right now through february
so uh but i can't i usually don't tour
at the same time
i can but like really it's for like
because i can't sell tickets in the same
market
for both tours right so if one of them
goes like if we're usually they take
pres the big one takes precedent right
and then when that's kind of through
i'll start mine or at least like six
months into it i'll start the dates that
was six months before it so it's like a
rolling thing but since the pandemic we
didn't have our fifth tour written yet
and i had mine so and i had to cancel my
tour from before the pandemic so so now
i've been on tour the whole year and we
don't start with them until february so
that we're gonna start writing that now
that's stressful too because
we don't do right comedy the way that we
would individually so uh we got to do
this like whole different process but
they'll put up the sales the tickets
before we even have a joke written so i
get like massive anxiety pressure this
is like the fifth tour like over 10
years that that that's happening every
two years when we're in this phase i get
i get like
chest pains like it all all the stress
manifests itself yeah i got like
shooting pains in like my head and [ __ ]
oh dude i've had that [ __ ]
ekgs this that and like stress and it's
always this time oh because it's so
nerve-wracking to have people buying
tickets to a show that you haven't
written a joke to yet can you imagine
that it's like i get like nauseous yeah
yeah well i mean it's i think it's nice
because it says something about that you
want to show up with something
legitimate for people yeah you know you
want to actually show you know some
people wouldn't care that it's like yeah
sell them whatever i'll get out there
but you gotta juggle yeah i know i know
but
i mean you know it's different too
with other people oh yeah yeah yeah i'm
sure that it's a totally different
energy out there um yeah i know whenever
you said you came in you were taking
your medicine you said you just started
taking one
yeah i started like i guess it's got to
be at least six months now oh wow
wellbutrin uh and you've been on there
how well butrin is that gangster baby is
it you told me that i didn't know it's
the hitman of freaking real i think
i can feel that [ __ ] climbing up and
down my cerebellum at night bro really
scaling the walls yeah well future baby
damn that [ __ ] you've tried you've been
on it that [ __ ] keeps a hatchet on its
hip baby
for me it did well butrin i i was doing
i got i started doing kind of some weird
like a little bit of like
not weird stuff but
i like couldn't i wasn't doing good i
started spinning out yeah but you feel
good on it
yeah well i was spitting out before
really
yeah so i i talked to a couple people a
couple people i know were on it so i so
i was trying to tackle two things with
my doctor one was the anxiety and
depression and the other one was my adhd
and ocd
so he's like
both of those ones could affect the
other in some ways and we got to treat
one at a time so because we gotta
figure out what what you react well to
and not so he's like which one do you
want to tackle first so i'm like i've
been living with adhd you know in an ocd
forever yeah so like i i didn't even
know
i didn't even know i had it until people
started telling me oh no and then i and
then i realized like oh you don't have
to live this way like i didn't even know
that before i just thought it was like
normal to not remember anything to have
[ __ ] racing through my mind at all times
you know what i mean like all that stuff
i just that's the way i always can't
focus on anything but i just like it's
the way i've always done it so i just
just do it and just function with it
right you thought this is who i am and
then i had a really good friend tell me
like that he had all that stuff and he
gave me a book and
i didn't read the book
but he was like i'm telling you you
don't have to live this way at all so i
went and i got a i went and i four years
ago i went and when he gave me that book
and i said forget i'll go i took a test
you know and i would they put me they
put like straps on my wrists ankles and
head really yeah and head yeah like like
like that straps like hold me down but
like uh bands
right did you ever take that you have
you have anything like that adhd or
anything i don't know i don't think i've
had it i could have it though yeah
i don't know so i went right so i go in
this little room they sit in front of a
computer
and they and they say all right take the
mouse and they're like you're just gonna
for like 20 25 minutes you're gonna sit
in here and you're gonna watch a screen
and when you see like a shape click on
the shape or whatever like some real
rudimentary [ __ ] yeah so i was like oh
yeah well guess so they put the [ __ ] on
me i went in there 20 minutes and i'm
seeing a triangle i'm clicking a circle
i'm clicking and i'm like this is the
easiest thing and i started to get
worried because i'm like i'm acing this
right like they're going to tell me i
don't have this [ __ ] right and i'm i'm
here because i'm at my wit's end with it
and they're about to tell me i don't
have it
so i'm just clicking and clicking i'm
like i'm dominating god i thought i got
a hundred and then they came in they
took the thing they took the print out
they came back to assess and they go you
have severe
adhd severe wow so i don't know what the
test really was i don't know if it was i
like measuring my fidgeting but i don't
know how that's in the i don't know how
it works i should have asked but so then
they tried to give me uh what's that
stuff that like hyper focuses you oh uh
ritalin no no the other one
oh yeah ritalin for adults us um like
it's like uh it's like speed
yeah it's crazy it's like uh people
snort it too yeah it's like it's like
very very common i don't know why it's
blanking yeah why can't we think of it
it's like um i think it starts with a um
what a yeah i think it starts with a
dude do you do i don't know what it is
anybody
adderall
adderall
damn
they gave me a time release adderall 20
20 and
milligrams whatever it is it's like the
game it's like a game show with drugs
just now
it's like that uh what is that uh okay
uh blue pill
it's like wouldn't that be crazy
that's the future dude why viagra i know
the future's just a game show which is
people just
all the answers are drug names just
trying to win the drugs yeah over tracks
uh go on though i interrupted you man
and they gave me that and i said you
know i don't really i don't really like
taking
any kind of drugs for sure i mean i
smoke weed but prescription and he's
like all right here's what we do take it
down days you think you really need it
that's it like not to just take on daisy
so i waited and then one day i had a day
so i was like let's try it i took it it
was the worst experience it was it was
terrible dude on adderall
yeah uh i stayed up for two days i
didn't go to sleep two days and sweating
profusely for two days and you get
dehydrated too on it that's the crazy
thing dude i so the whole the first
night came
and i was i was like wired all day and
then my lady went to sleep and i was
like i'll be to sleep in a little while
it was like the stereotypical thing i
stayed up all night clean the house was
scrubbing [ __ ] it was really
stereotypical like yeah and then i and
then i started like my heart was beating
on my chest i was
pouring sweat i look like i just i was
jogging i was just in the house and i
woke her up i'm like this doesn't feel
good man and she's like this is insane
you know whatever but then she had to go
back to bed
so but then i was like oh that's love
right there
yeah
no she's like you want to go to the
hospital i was like no and she's like
what do you want to do i'm like there's
nothing i can do i was like i'm just
going to keep cleaning i don't want to
do a puzzle
i want to open a business
right
and then like all right
wake me up in an hour bro my friend
sometimes i'd be so coke down and i'd
have him around i'd be like bro you
gotta come spend some time with me he'd
come over and he's like uh you're
probably gonna be fine dude wake me up
in an hour
was it comforting just to know he was
there i don't know because it's just
talking about his body then i started
tripping in circles because i'm like i
just finally started to fall asleep i'm
like [ __ ] i gotta wake this dude up in
an hour
now you have a chore now i gotta stay
here
he came there and gave you a
responsibility now i gotta stay up to
wake this [ __ ] creep up
yeah man but then i thought i was gonna
fall asleep that night uh-huh didn't and
i'm like all right someday the next day
i'm gonna crash i didn't
i stayed up through two nights damn
you're like sully sullivan
or whatever that guy's name is that the
guy went to the plane yeah yeah
dude will not crash
it will not crash
that's funny dude no i i i i took two
days it was a time release formula
apparently
and um and then i never took it again
and then like like when i was getting on
the world butcher i was talking to my
doctor now who who i trust way more who
is like my childhood my i went to high
school with him so
trust him and um
he was like whoever gave you that gave
you the wrong dose the wrong kind the
wrong everything he's like that could be
effective for you but not in that way so
we started he said let's start with the
anxiety and depression because
you know that that was really pronounced
coming out of the couple of years that
we had and all that stuff like that and
i already lived with that i already
just had that yeah from growing up yeah
yeah yeah yeah so so uh yeah so so i
started with the wellbutrin i didn't
feel nothing but he said it'll take a
few weeks and and now i feel like kind
of adjusted to it yeah and i you know
it's hard to it's like not a magic pill
they're saying it's hard to sometimes
discern because it's not like i'm
bulletproof now no i still like
you know sometimes can't get out of bed
yeah or still like you know i wake up
and go to bed to my mind racing and
worrying all day long about [ __ ] oh yeah
you know but um but it is definitely
better it is it was yeah yeah it's
almost like i can kind of like
it's not as frequent and not as severe
yeah if that makes any sense yeah i feel
like it kind of puts like bumpers on
thing it's like yeah you're still
bowling and the balls just to every ball
still going right in the thing all
morning but there's bumpers on there
it's like the sound is softer it doesn't
hit as heavy exactly exactly right yeah
they kind of take away the symbols you
know yep um so yeah but i didn't know it
was like you said it was
for me it was crazy i remember i was
trying to decide on something to do and
i got into some like loop and i couldn't
get out i couldn't make a decision and
when i would make a decision my brain
would serve the same issue back to me
like i hadn't made a decision and so
yeah just that medicine i had a bad
reaction to so right now i'm just on a
low dose lexapro right now
i so i took that
like a few years ago
and same thing low dose every day that
was my first try of anything and that
worked i felt that work kind of pretty
fast but then it
it affected disappeared yeah yeah
sexually no good oh
well see thankfully i've never been
really great sexually so it's like i'm
[ __ ] you know i'm like yeah i'll take
the pills dude
i'll put a pill in the end
i'll take the wiener laws you know what
i'm saying dude i paid down 700
milligrams of zoloft right to the head
of my people
you know it's just
but dude i got on zoloft could we take
medicine that way though
oh like people take suppositories like a
subpoena yeah subpinator yeah that's not
crazy he might have just invented
something
dude
last thing we want is dudes slipping off
and stuff and pills up their wings
that's because it doesn't exist yet i
don't think you know if you want it yet
yeah you're right what if they you know
they're not stupid the people that make
these things yeah what if they make it
amenable
what does it mean
like it's just you know it's it's
it's not that bad it's it's you're okay
with it you know like yeah oh wow it's
agreeable you know what i mean yeah and
then all of a sudden like you just gotta
like just
hey i mean i don't know how that's
easier than putting it in your mouth but
what if somebody's hanging fun burned
yeah
it's a little more of a game show yeah
what if somebody your hands are burned
or something you're at a bar and you
have to have your buddy stuff one up you
know that's would be a problem hey donny
hit me with this yeah i would switch
back to oral yeah
did you ever do have to do suppositories
when you were growing up yo i i remember
them
i don't remember if they went up me but
they must they must have because they
went up my sister i know that cause one
time my sister was real little she was
like three and like my mom was trying to
give her one and i forget why i don't
know when we were sick i do a bit on
this actually about how they used to
take our temperature up our swimming a
little too yeah yeah which is [ __ ]
wild right now they have a laser gun
yeah you know and they used to stick
that [ __ ] up our ass like i don't
understand what they were getting at
like it was more definitely more area 51
back then right yeah like i was like i
don't know why my word to this woman
that i don't feel well isn't good enough
yeah well feel my forehead you know yeah
but then they'd be like no let's let's
let's stick this up your ass against
your will
and really get to the bottom of it let's
really get that temp you know like he
feels warm but i want to know to the to
the decimal so let's shove this glass
right up his anus
penetrate this sick [ __ ]
we'll never know if he needs a cough
drop it doesn't make any sense you know
what i mean
can you pull up suppositories let's see
let's see some informational
suppositories here i'm interested about
that i hadn't thought of it in a while
but when you said it an immediate memory
came back to me that i hadn't had in
forever my mom's trying to give my
sister one and you know when you're
young you know it's medicine but my
sister's crying you know she didn't want
that you know it's just weird all around
it's very weird right and so i remember
being like getting that defensiveness
from my sister right and i was like i
was like leave her alone you know like i
was like she's like two or three years
younger than me and i'm like stop she
doesn't want to do it leave her alone
like i'm breaking up around
like i'm breaking up something something
like making up for sex crime yeah
and i remember telling your mom i was
like when i was like stop she had to
change i'm like no and then my big thing
was i kept going like coming out the
doorway and shutting the light
so then it went like pitch black and
then she like stop it and she put on the
light and i run back and shut the light
like i'll save you
it's like it's like dude that's the
person practical joke did
you're like suppository but no lights
oh man what they create and how to use
medicine can get into your body a
suppository is another way to deliver a
drug small round or cone-shaped object
you put in your body often in your
bottom
what about the history of suppositories
i mean give the history of them but who
who said
let's put this up your ass instead of
just like swallow this well because i
think they didn't know maybe
they might not have had as much science
as to how quick things need to get into
your body maybe that
or that they could get into
because i know the s one of the colons
like will really absorb stuff real fast
oh really yeah because i think they pull
all the vitamins and stuff out of your
body right
so that's what they're doing with food
like they're really you know they're
really it's a royal rumble down there
and they're pulling out all the vitamins
so i think they're like oh this will get
the quickest into the bloodstream okay
okay
you know it's um sometimes you see uh
someone they trying to tell you
something you don't know what they're
saying
and that is because they are speaking
another language
and you might not realize it because you
don't know what's going on well babel
is the language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
it's an addictively fun and easy way to
learn a new language not your current
one get different
babble you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian and german there are so many
ways to learn with babel in additional
lessons you can access podcasts games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee start your new language
learning journey
today
with babel
and right now
save up to 60 off your subscription when
you go to b a b b e l dot com slash theo
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
slash theo for up to sixty percent off
your subscription babel
language for life language
you know i just snagged me a pair of
ease and they are uh
good they make my eyes feel good make my
eyes feel safe too that's what i like
having safe eyes
and uh and also where are you gonna find
a pair of sunglasses called mud
wrestling with nerdy
well luckily our friends over at gooder
have created the ultimate sunglasses
collection from a to z
at just 25 dollars a pair
gooder makes clean durable or durable
100 polarized sunglasses you don't have
to worry about losing that's right
well most you don't help 25 bucks is a
decent amount
but
if you lose them it's not like losing
that big daddy pair solid gold something
forty eight hundred dollar pair or
something go pick up a pair of a ginger
soul or going to valhalla
with this exclusive offer head to
gooder.comddr.com
t-h-e-o
and use code theo for 15 off that's
g-o-o-d-r
dot c-o-m-slash
t-h-e-o-g-o-o-d
dot com slash
theo and use code theo for 15 off
protect your eyes and see the future
well with gooder
they got them baby
and the sun sometimes you can't even you
know the sun will hit you don't know
what's happening can't drive can't see
can't steal on your horse either well
that can all change with gooder
get some
king henry ii was wounded in a jousting
accident his body could not retain fluid
by mouth his doctors used a rectal
suppository to keep the king alive
ass to mouth bro did they well he just
said by mouth oh yeah the rectal
suppository
which is very
unorthodox yeah i don't know what really
is that about like we haven't i don't
even know if there was just a a rectal
suppository i and they tried to put it
in my mouth i might even say you know
what just correctly
i don't want that in my mouth either we
have to swallow so fast for it to get
down to your butt anyway
some let me see in 1897 glycerin
suppositories in 1897 cocoa butter
suppositories began to be mixed with
water
gelatin and glycerin for easier
insertion at the end of the world war ii
suppositories began being made with hard
uh fats
the whole point was to make this
depository experience easier and more
comfortable
yeah well i got that there was a meeting
and someone was like let's throw cocoa
butter in there yeah you know like a
nice smooth fresh smelling inside oh
it's like a little it's like a it's like
going to maui for your butthole
uh it's his internet let me look a
little bit more here suppositories
um
the benefited fathers were known long
before the 21st century but low quality
capsules and liquids have given rise to
the demand for suppositories why isn't
it called a depository
yeah depository huh right
because that's where you really that's
where you deposit right
yeah
it makes sense i don't know what a
suppository is here's the here's where
here's our fact that we need she's like
i suppose this may work
[Laughter]
we've been saying it wrong the whole
time it's just suppository it's like it
goes nothing
yeah
well you might die but i suppose we have
one last thing to try
dude it's like
that sounds like something that uh
like um that sounds like like if you
only have like a cheap insurance it's
like
this guy
it's like yeah uh
oh hey hold on here's this last thing um
you got some magic beans when a liquid
or capsule supplement reaches the
stomach stomach acids will largely
destroy
the nutrients through the digestion
process after the digestion process less
than 10 of the capsule or liquid
supplement will be absorbed in the
bloodstream
um
[Music]
so if you swallow yeah if you swallow
through the stomach acids so they
thought dang we're gonna beat the
stomach and go straight to the butt okay
wow
so
oh that's the big one how long do you
keep a suppository in
oh i thought you just put it in and
forget about it
like a crock pot
you know okay
i thought you just put it in and it
dissipates it melts i think you gotta go
back and get it wait wait wait wait wait
then my confusion on what's going on
here you better you have to go back you
better because they're like lost they
gotta go back
and get it you better call your sister
she might have a couple loose in there
that we i didn't know the process
i thought it was like you put it in and
then it just like when you swallowed
something you forget about you set it
and you forget it
if you use one more cooking term
wow dude no i think you got to go back
and get if you pat your sister on the
back does she rattle a little
we might we all might have a few in us
that we don't just banging around
so then i really don't know how that
works oh you go half inch for infants
and one inch for adults
oh there's a tool they use to do it see
once the suppository has completely
melted
you can expect a bowel movement within
15 minutes to an hour
oh so how much oh so you gotta
but oh so maybe you you battle it out
you know
but i don't understand what do you what
are you taking back
what are you getting back what's this
you get back the shell
like shell case like the bullet yeah
i guess
so are you not just putting the actual
pill in your ass or whatever it is like
it's not just a pill that
will then just like look how we take
vitamins or whatever right okay but yeah
that looks like i guess that's the way
that it transports it it looks like a
little bullet yeah you know so you
popping shells out there yeah damn
well
well
did you ever think that you'd be on
medication
were you against it or you just never
really gotten introduced to it the right
way same yeah yeah
i don't know you just
this i just look at prescriptions just
like
peop it's just [ __ ] up like the world
we live in is [ __ ] up by prescription
medication you know the commercials like
you'll [ __ ] die probably or maybe so
it's like all right just do i really
maybe i'll just be depressed a little
bit and then maybe not have
diarrhea and maybe you know however yeah
yeah are your teeth falling out yeah no
something like that can you can you if
you can't stop putting on hats it's like
what yeah
it's something forever it's crazy
because a buddy of mine uh couldn't stop
putting on hats really yeah and he was
he was driving he was going nuts with it
so
he went and got that no i mean i you
know dude a buddy of mine oh you are
yeah you know i have a friend who just
couldn't stop
putting on hats yeah for sure
that was a medication for it i wouldn't
be shocked
or you know some type of attention
disorder or something all right
you know i didn't know how a tampon
worked for a lot most of my life really
yeah because i never really saw it in
action yeah just like the bullet you
know which is great yeah and what what
that you hadn't seen in an action
it's fine no there's no need you know
there's no need but i remember one of my
friends blew my mind because i just
thought you put the whole thing in there
and then you know that's that yeah but
no that is also just the receptacle that
bullet hmm
did you know that
like do you know how that works i never
really thought about it yeah i guess
there's a retrieval process huh yeah i
think that you
you put it in and then you that plastic
thing it's in i thought that used to go
in there yeah it that just comes out of
the way and it's just like a little like
like cotton ball at the end of a rope oh
yeah
wow
so it's not as uh
it doesn't sound as
it sounds a little more simpler it is
simple right yeah i thought there was
technology too yeah i thought they
really had a real like uh almost like um
like those braces or somebody that has
like a bad jaw you know i thought they
had a little bit more uh of a template
going on there yeah me too i thought it
was like you know those nails that you
put into the wall that they they once
they go in they spread out so they can't
come back
i thought like you put it in there and
the plastic like opened up and i was
like and that's what kept it yeah it
shuts it then you have to pull it with
the rope yeah yeah but it's not it
literally is just like a cotton ball at
the end of a string
it should come with a little sign they
put on their leg it's like go around you
know or like uh
seats taken you know
they should be like
like uh almost like uh uh what do you
call those china what do you call those
things a fortune cookie
just a little fortune on it
winning numbers just make it fun you
know because everyone it's already tough
you know when that when that thing comes
around it's already tough it's cramps is
it
i would hate it i would hate it oh if i
had to have it thank you
imagine if every once a month you ate a
really bad chicken sandwich dude and it
wouldn't leave you for like a week yeah
i can't imagine it and it got to say it
got lodged into your bowels and started
flapping its wings dude yeah
that's what's up that's what i heard
it's like oh my friend's daughter used
to work at a chicken
my friends owned a chicken sandwich
place and his daughter used to work
there and she told me that one time and
it blew my mind she told you that
she goes imagine if he had a really bad
chicken sandwich and then he got once a
month and it got lodged in your bowels
and started flapping its wings
i was like wow yeah and she her father
owned the chicken place so
so they have you know that's
that's good knowledge i feel like um
right you know she might have first-hand
knowledge of a bad chicken sandwich
right and she's like this is exactly
what it's like oh wow
yeah that's a good way to describe it
dude i had a buddy who bit into who ate
one of those subway uh
i had a friend who ate a starbucks
sandwich mm-hmm and he couldn't ken
can't open his eyes he's in like a
lawsuit actually can you look that up
man can't see after a starbucks sandwich
or something like that you made the
paper huh your friend man no oh yeah i
mean i'm sure there's got to be
something on it
oh all right but he he hadn't been able
to see since he had this [ __ ]
sandwich
that's the most insane thing i've ever
heard
what did he what's which sandwich
there was something that vex face staff
what do we have here
i think it was the impossible one
i mean it's
apropos
yeah that's a good point if you put that
in the title though does that cover you
he said like anything can happen with
this you know don't
you you're not going to believe this but
i know it's going to sound impossible
but there's a chance you might lose your
vision
no i mean that's i mean
starbucks your your buddy's going to be
like
your buddy's going to own starbucks
he might own one or two i don't know how
much they cost to do the uh thing to do
the um
what's it called when you give them out
but you make people pay for them
the businesses you give them out or you
know it's like um
oh franchise franchise yeah okay he he's
gonna get a franchise out of it i don't
know
people sue i mean look there's been
there's certainly been people that have
had things happen and what they wanted
in the lawsuit was the actual business
it was actually yeah yeah like that
seinfeld episode with jackie childs he
gets coffee spilled on him and they give
him free coffee for life and he's like
i'll take it
that's wild man
but yeah mandy um would you
which sense would you lose if you had to
lose one got to be smell right let me
think
yeah i already can't smell that good so
i would probably do sight would be so
hard man you can't right
you go in sight or sound first if you
had to choose
sound
you you'd lose sound first because you
could always just
guess what's happening
yeah and you could use you could sign
language yeah or guess the sounds
okay
you mean like if you saw a band
you'd know like the sound that was
making yeah and also if they suck you
can just play your favorite song in your
head
well people like are very capable that
are
deaf you know like they live normal
lives right because blind people do too
but yeah i think i would lose
i don't know man that's gotta be so
[ __ ] tough but smell could smell [ __ ]
it right i mean like i would just be
like take the smell yeah take it i know
someone who was born without a sense of
smell
it fascinates me they never smelled the
thing
yeah isn't that like mild yeah it's
unbelievable kyle who's to work with you
think it helps him or do you think it
makes things does he seem different you
have any more intel on him he
i know him so he's i would never you
would never know it ever until he told
us
and uh he was born that way like so he's
never smelled a thing
and you know you wouldn't know it but
like i don't know i guess in that way
you don't know what you're missing
yeah i would think but food can't be as
good it's because it's
things that are a sensory experience you
know like
he doesn't experience you know if you if
you just took a shower and you were
cologned up or something like that yeah
are you just your natural musk yeah you
know your pheromones he might not even
fall in love with you and you might have
the best hormones out there oh my god
because pheromones go through your nose
i think
can you look that up please sir
how do we know about pheromones
but he's never like you know coffee in
the morning or bacon cooking or
garlic for a spaghetti sauce or
something like that
now bacon cooking breakfast cooking that
would [ __ ] that would hurt a little man
when you know that somebody
gave a [ __ ] enough in the in the house
to heat up a damn grill when you wake up
that way it's like already a good day
you're like
that's those little things he's never
experienced isn't that wild yeah
best smells
best smells i think definitely something
cooking and you're saying something like
with garlic that does smell good
bacon smells good breakfast smells good
bakeries
do it past the bakery i want to punch
somebody in the mouth
[Laughter]
carnivals i feel like have a smell like
when's the last thing you went to a
carnival oh i went to one oh dude i'll
tell you this i went to one uh a while
back and they had the roller thing or
the spinning wheel
went through they had a bee's nest up
there dude so it's just
it goes around what do you mean
like a ferris wheel the ferris wheel no
way
there was a business on top no not on
top of the thing but up in one of the
trees up there so every now and then no
way sat the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's hysterical that's terrorizing
dude because you know that guy ain't
stopping you know it's like you used to
play stuff yeah you remember when you
were a kid you went on you like please
stop they didn't stop that [ __ ]
i think that dude
screaming
he was like that chef from the muppets i
don't think that guy had any
he had no senses and remember the um the
the spinning around one with the um
gravitron remember that yeah i wouldn't
[ __ ] with that one i can't no no i can't
you did oh we're like your centrifugal
force kept you on a thing that's so and
then it would lift up and some of them
would tilt and [ __ ] to me that's
there's things that are fun like i'll do
a scrambler oh you know
scrambler is what i could do but that
just spin around and just see your whole
equilibrium get like i didn't see the
point of that whatsoever and that's the
one where people would throw up and just
it would spray everybody and you ran
that risk if you went on that and i saw
that
i saw that often you saw that often oh
yeah there was one there's the outdoor
one but there's then there's the one
where you go it looks like a ufo yeah
and then you ain't getting out of here
there at all you know what i mean like
yes the guy in the middle was always
playing rock and roll oh yeah and this
dude was all perved out dude and he
would get his [ __ ] wiener out bro and
you couldn't help but look at it so he
like had you trapped in like this like
weiner vision kind of did you think like
maybe because you were going so fast you
just caught a glimpse if you're like
maybe i'm just seeing something totally
yeah so this guy's tricking everybody
yeah so he's a perfect job for him
though
perfect job instead of having to be a
peep in time you're just bringing them
all to you right you know and it's just
a blur and you're like was that was that
his was that his
and then then you get off you threw up
you don't even you know you're just too
sick to worry about yeah there was that
other one you remember the one i think
it was called like it's called different
things but maybe like the avalanche or
something so it's you get in a cart
right so me and you are sitting together
two maybe two behind us okay and then it
goes in a circle but it goes up and down
in a circle it's outside and there's a
dj it's at all like like the old school
ones
full of avalanche can we see what we're
seeing here brother and and it goes in a
circle but it goes up and down in a
circle and it starts going faster and
faster and they're playing like you know
hip like jukebox hero and they're
blasting it and it's so what happens is
the person on the outside gets [ __ ]
crushed
but you're laughing and then they do it
in reverse you never did this one
this is like this is a this is a very
popular one the avalanche yeah this is
it
oh no that not that one
it goes in in a circle the zipper oh
about that right there see that see that
one right there to the bottom down yeah
that's it maybe it's i always thought it
was something like the snow snowstorm or
the avalanche or whatever oh that's the
uh
and all these things are always under
the shadiest llc's because
okay these things are just a way to see
how it goes up and down like the
himalaya the
yeah damn
that thing was fun i would do that one
that himalaya daddy damn i remember um
[Music]
they had um the zipper was the scariest
one
and people would damn i mean just people
would be vomiting up ejaculate i mean
people were just getting so sick on that
and rattled
i know i don't know
oh yeah see i don't i wouldn't do that
here oh that's when those things are
flipping and sliding so it's three
things right it's going around but then
those things are sliding themselves and
then the individual pods are
circling oh yeah so it's triple it that
that to me i don't i don't understand
that i don't even understand how anyone
would want to go on that yeah because
you don't have any there's no real sense
i don't feel like of joy it's just a
total sense of hey [ __ ] you yeah endure
it yes you know what i mean like that's
what it's like it's like hey endure
exactly it looks like it would be like a
you know a
torture trap or something like that yeah
it's very
it does have a very german vibe to it
um you hear you know you know when you
go to a carnival and everything they
just pull up with like the trucks and
they open them up and they start
building that [ __ ] like in a parking lot
like those like not like six flags like
those yeah those are those are crazy
shady you said like the llc's and the
people running them are just
drug ad like guy like stoners just
straight stoners and like i've seen one
where the truck was like losing balance
you see them on you could you to them
all time like that the avalanche like
you see it like almost gonna and the
people jump on it to weigh it down
people are saving people all the time oh
you see like they're on the swings and
then you just see someone launch
now how does that not close the swings
down for life
like the guy tried to light his shoes on
a plane
it didn't even work yeah 20 years ago we
take off our shoes right now people are
being launched from those swings like
every few days
there's no rules because look i think
like
i think there's part of you that wants
to see
that's for you i think if you get thrown
on that thing you want to almost get
thrown again to see how far you can go
you want to beat your distance you're
dead yeah you know you are dead google
what percentage of people die from a
carnival accident
that's a stat
oh yeah you know what percentage of
people die out of the people on the
earth
it's gonna be low or people that get
into the accidents you know what i'm
talking about brother how often did
someone get into an accident on this
thing
yeah like how
how likely are you to get into an
accident on this
zipper
i don't know how we can even do all the
math i guess yeah it would take a lot i
would love to see the stat
damn man
but carnival rod accidents occur more
than we think oh there we go um i don't
know if that's true
i think they occur a decent amount um
when i was uh younger we went to the
giant stadium it was usually the
meadowlands mm-hmm and uh oh yeah was it
cool they had a meadowlands fair and it
was the biggest one in our area bar none
all new york
oh i bet a lot of hotties huh oh yeah a
lot yeah
summer months
yeah but they they would like really
like it was big too they set up the
whole thing yeah but they would have
cool stuff like i saw a baby get hurt
but not so my friend and i strong baby
though like frankie edgar yeah
like frankie edgar about his size and uh
i love frankie dude me too i uh dude i
had a frankie edgar was in my dream last
night i never realized yeah as a baby
i mean if he was he was pound for pound
the best baby out there i'll say that no
as a result man i love that guy as an
adult no i love him too man um
that's so crazy some of that anyway go
on go on no no my friend was throwing uh
softballs like legit softballs like to
win some some [ __ ] i forgot what what he
would but oh no i know what it was it
was a baseball and it was like they put
the glass bottles on the shelves and you
could just launch them and try all
plates
and what happened was
the he he threw a baseball as hard as he
could but it hit the wood
underneath the thing and just came
flying back at us at nearly the same
speed and we moved and it hit the ground
popped up and went right into a carriage
right into a baby carriage oh mom my dad
you just heard the baby screaming and we
were like oh my [ __ ] god and we just
like literally like like just
like abandon him yeah wow and that baby
now is adam frazier who plays for the
seattle mariners guys he's a second
baseman and he's doing well i hope that
i don't think the baby got like mauled
but like a baseball definitely disrupted
its flow in there
and then it was screaming like you know
crying i don't know if it got like
clipped or anything but well i'm sure
every time it sees like a solar eclipse
it can't help it go like that
anything round come on dude yeah even if
you just whisper take me
i'm sure you can't get a suppository in
it after that i bet it's a little tight
buddy damn but they had weird [ __ ] like
they used to do also carney stuff
the meadowlands so it's like you know
you so what it says is like pay a dollar
okay and go behind this thing oh yeah
and see the church the wolf man or the
world's smallest horse i met i met the
world's smallest horse tom thumb
a couple years back i might be able to
pull that up on my instagram maybe
somebody can and send you the link it
might be it's at the bottom somewhere
where'd you
meet him he was touring in um
i guess um out there
out here somewhere california riverside
thomas is has a surname
tom thumb yeah
so i guess he does yeah i don't know was
he a great horse so how was he i mean
bro as far as horses go he was how
miniature
he was he had to be this big wow
it blew my mind
is that him right there
no that looks like a pig and [ __ ]
but then they kind of uh glued some hair
on his body huh that's a pig isn't it
thumbelina horse wow
also a thumb name a miniature horse it
could have been a sister of her then or
a brother of her well they had the
world's smallest woman now i don't know
if she was the world's smallest really
couldn't check that out at the time but
i paid the dollar yeah and uh it was
kind of wild
i went behind the thing and behind that
like the truck like was the sign on it
like meet the world's you know and i
don't know how i feel about
the whole thing yeah i guess she's
making money right she she might maybe
can't get a traditional job right so i
guess maybe she found a niche maybe she
has a family in the in the carnival
world like now you know she travels with
people it's social and she's getting
paid hopefully well but it did feel
weird to be like pay money to see this
you know because
the the the the the air around it is
that it was like a freak show in a way
okay i see what you're saying you know
what's kind of the original only fans it
feels like yeah in a way you're right
that's the just the like literal like
mono only like the the the lo-fi only
fans yeah
it is
it was a dollar yeah and it was a dollar
it's a fair and once a year for and what
a better deal you got
once a year you paid you saw you kept
the image with you throughout the year
you weren't really i remember this lady
right this second wow and i saw that her
like 30 years 20 years ago 25 years so i
went behind it and behind it she was in
like the
cut out of the trailer and inside of it
they made it look like a home
and she was sitting in a rocking chair
knitting
yeah she was like that big
oh
yeah
and what age was she she was looked
older she looked middle-aged like an
older woman thank god
why
i'm just glad she's had a life you know
like they're not out here like you know
just height trafficking or something you
know
you know she's got you know there's like
seven others i wanted this understudies
you know
you know because what if she gets sick
that's a revenue stream that's not gonna
shut down dude angela's sick
yeah man but it wasn't like dwarfism
unless it was but it was like but she
was like it wasn't like you know we like
that it was like she was like that big
yeah and she was sitting in a rocking
chair like a you know a miniature right
it look because i'll be honest it looked
very cozy and like oh like they made it
look really cozy like she actually
i wonder if she actually lived there now
i'm thinking about it she might have you
might like she might just be like
she might like they might close the
front and that's just her house because
it looked like a house in there let's
pull that up world's smallest woman can
we get some information here brother um
i'm trying to think of the yeah the
horse i saw was so small man you could
i bet it would be kind of nice to be so
small because your parts are right there
imagine taking a nap when you're so
little it must feel so good i get that
but in reality how far is your hand from
you like you you have you have
everything right there too though look
how far
you're imagining like this like that oh
hey buddy
there's just less time
it's just like yeah how quick you can
get a snack into you okay oh so yeah i
mean there are there's pros and cons to
everything like kevin durant probably
takes him a little over a second to get
a snack into his mouth you think yeah he
probably he's he hasn't experienced the
joys of the world's smallest woman
no
and to be able to just to open a peanut
you put it in one hand and then punch it
with the other
i never thought of that
oh so funny just like punching peanuts
at because it to her it's like
yeah the peanuts like a almost like a
circus peanut oh yeah right yeah
there you go yeah okay
omni that's not who i saw but is an
indian actors for being the world's
shortest living woman now i guess are we
saying shortest are we saying smallest
because there's a there's kind of
something different there
they i think from what i gather my
memory serves they said smallest okay
and this woman two foot three quarter
inch
how big is that wow
that's like what this woman was though
wow yeah so she might have just not
entered in the contest
there's no
there's no s
swimming ever
um i mean even a shallow end is three
feet
that's true huh there's no i mean
there's you have to
can you swim is your i wonder if you can
swim
with only that much propeller you know
what i'm saying kind of yeah but think
of like a chihuahua chihuahua can it's a
great point you know what i mean yeah
that's true i gotta say nothing though
who makes the clothes too ooh pervs
probably or they get them off dolls
i was thinking but like
you really think they get them off dolls
we had a small guy or school and his
daddy would get clothing off of some
dolls for him once in a while yeah
you know when you run a business it uh
time seems more precious
every misplaced moment feels like a
missed opportunity
you know running a business is hard you
got to come and you know stay on top of
things
communicate uh
capitulate
and
do stuff well
ship station helps you
ship station gives e-commerce sellers
like you
possibly more time to do what they
really love that's interesting
unless what you really love is managing
every single little detail of order
fulfillment i know you don't
i know you don't
some of you would ride in the dang
package if you could and go there with
the package
but ship station man they'll handle it
for you
they're already trusted by over 100 000
sellers that's a lot
it works with all storefronts amazon
ebay etsy and more moss
and lets you automate all the manual
work that goes into shipping automated
baby done done done
sign up using promo code theo for a free
60-day trial today at
shipstation.com saving time with every
shipment that's two whole months of
shipping made quick and painless and
it's free to try
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in t-h-e-o ship station make ship
happen
you know if you're feeling burnt out
it's because you are i have been
and i've had it for a few years now it's
been grueling
to get over
been grueling it's been hard hard to
manage myself
and it can happen in in many ways uh it
can feel different for different people
you know burnout is usually associated
with work but that's not the only cause
any of your roles can make you feel
burnt out
being a parent being a sibling being a
dang employee or being a boss
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
that's right talking with someone can
help me figure out what's causing stress
in your life
i just got off the
line with my therapist so
you can use it better help
um
is customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist i did a
live chat session so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
help is on the way
you know if you are feeling closed up or
uh alone
try something
this past weekend listeners get 10 off
their first month at
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash theo
i mean some dolls you know they have
some like i could see it on some dolls
well dolls have a lot of nice stuff
these days here we go right here play it
up get that volume out
everyone can meet the world how long are
you going to be here today for uh
he'll be here all day
how small is he de las grandes
de kansas ls mas
[Laughter]
you may want to take him home
did you go in oh yeah i went oh he
wouldn't let you take the camera in
no
oh wow that's ip i guess he was so small
man god i still remember him
how do you yeah you seem like you said
oh i don't know if i feel sad i guess
that's nostalgic it was a fun day at
that fair
though smallest woman can ride that
smallest horse oh beautiful and and they
probably are in the same fair so
maybe it's like she's trotting around on
that thing i'm sure at night they meet
up dude i remember one time i was in
iraq doing a military show and one lady
hit me up on social media and uh offered
to meet me in a blackhawk helicopter
and give me a um
blow job give me a little bit of oral
and uh
and i didn't do it man i got just too
nerved out you know it's a unique
scenario for sure yeah and i just didn't
know what protocol was i don't want to
be some dude
who looks like an insurgent or whatever
yeah you know because i have long hair
yeah so i just didn't want it this lady
was on the clock this lady was a
bonafide military woman really oh yeah
now did she think the [ __ ] offer in
and of itself wasn't gonna be enough
like why did she sweeten the deal with a
black hawk helicopter she just said the
flight is uh
the flight thing isn't secure tonight or
whatever so we could meet up in a
blackhawk and i'll give you a [ __ ]
but you weren't gonna take flight
no no no no no maybe in here you were
yeah maybe in my head dude but yeah no
but and uh and also i remember this is
this is the part i feel worse about kind
of is this she had a huge either a
animal had bitten her on the neck or a
huge acne a huge one acne okay
and uh i was just like
i felt like it would almost be a game
show what was gonna bust first
[Music]
i can see now where the hesitation came
in yeah you know because but if there
were if that wasn't there would you have
been blackhawk down on that oh yeah yeah
yeah that's blackhawk now that's her
version
she uh you know if the goiter if the
quarter wasn't there you would have had
that experience because that's almost
hard to turn down like it would take a
goiter or something like that to to to
thwart this experience i should not have
turned it down
god what an idiot because it's a good
story that it was offered but it would
be an amazing story got it i know
i think i was just so i didn't know if
we would be what if we got caught and
then i'm giving a bad look to this group
there was just some other implications
and dude some other lady don't if you go
over there for the military dude
somebody will they'll do sex with your
brother men or women
because they had people i mean out on
their morning jog stopping by to see
what was going on another lady tried to
come by and have sex one time
they must
like the single
single people in the military
must
bang each other like there's nobody's
business they must because they know
they're only gonna be there for a few
years you know
i think it gets kind of territorial
though i had a friend of mine marry a
sailor that came in for fleet week what
yeah i used to work at this neighborhood
bar and we were on the water in staten
island and every year the same week all
the sailors came in and they would
invade the town you know would they wear
their uniforms full-on they know what
they're doing they bring it up sailor
uniform they would wear the uniform
because
first of all we we give them a lot of
free drinks because thank you for your
military yeah and then they and then the
chicks you know they pick up and even
the female officers would come in
like you know and everybody rhymes yeah
yeah yeah and they would all wear it
well that definitely is from party city
we are members of
the young yeah that's part of when you
look at a real military uniform
and uh yeah this girl i knew uh just
started dating this guy they ended up
getting married
wow like that or like oh there we go no
white in the whites okay
let's see a white military you know the
difference there you go like that on the
right the top right over there that's
what they were calling
with the hat too
i swear
yeah yeah they had dude oh and they were
coming packs
so like all of a sudden like 50 10 10 or
10 sailors
men and women yeah yeah yeah but they
sing songs no
week yeah that's a week dude bro
remember the cruise we went on a lot of
sauteed spinach really yeah no no oh
that was a popeye reference that didn't
land
remember him
oh
hell yeah remember live action popeye
though
yeah robin williams play popeye diddy he
did the voice he did he didn't do the
void
live action yeah like a real film i'm
talking about the cartoon can we get
that cartoon of popeye
yeah but but you've never seen robin
williams play popeye
with uh chelly duvall as olive oil never
dude it is a classic
i never knew this existed and i cannot
wait look at his forearms oh it's great
oh wow
yo this is one of the tapes i played
till it broke when i was like oh
dude i'm so excited to watch this i
didn't know this existed i didn't know
the head there you're going to like this
man he fights a giant squid
yeah
yeah when i was little like popeye was i
don't think kids know popeye today no i
don't think they know about it in popeye
also who did the voice for popeye the
cartoon there you go there he was
yeah
[Music]
and you know because that was like the
original gi joe was popeye yeah like
people don't realize that that's who we
pop eye out i had popeye on the video
game too
i don't think we had that but we had
papa's chicken in louisiana so
everywhere is that is that yeah is that
him it was oh it was because you used to
get the figurine if you went over there
to give you the figure really so that's
his fried chicken i don't i don't get
the connection
yeah
uh the sailor and the fried chicken i
don't get it i think they just i think
they had named it pop pies and then
retro retrofitted the tim they might
have
let's uh so jack mercer did the voice
there for popeye the sailor
can you get the youtube of jack mercer
doing that voice or well that we won't
be able to use it
you started to say something when i said
popeye that i i was like oh [ __ ] yeah
our cruise we went i went oh right on
right on right on yeah they just had a
cruise issue was that thing in the news
too let's
let's i want to hear this jack mercer do
the voice can we see him do the voice
i ate spinach because of him
i didn't like spinach i didn't like
veggies you know and i wouldn't eat it
and my dad would be like
one
and a two
and a pair of threes the votes are all
in
well
whether or not something of the voice
would create through there and it worked
out beautifully number one mr goldwater
i don't think this is it you do
south amboy new jersey plan no he's not
this used this as a question you think
no i think he was he was on that game
show that was to tell the truth so for
those people are like lying about who
they are once telling the truth it was
old game show oh so he was the
contestant telling the truth as the
voice of popeye
hmm
do we have jack mercer does voice of
popeye
i just wanted to hear it again
i wish i could do that voice
yeah wouldn't you do voices if you could
all day oh i'll do this
see me tell me who this is okay
they said it would take a man 600 years
to get out of the sea of prison but andy
dufresne did it in less than 20.
yeah
that's a little weak today but no that's
that's that's morgan freeman thanks yeah
that was good actually thanks man i
closed my eyes for a little bit of it i
i see where you were going with it if
it's something you don't do all the time
i i felt
there was something in there yeah yeah i
don't do voices though
um you don't i don't i wish i could
we had kyle dunnigan was on he does him
really well you ever do voiceovers
you ever get in the animated show um i
got offered two animations such a good
voice oh thanks man you have a strong
distinct voice with good diction thank
you yeah you do that's easy that's very
easy to tell i do i uh i
sal sorry i don't know why i called you
i i didn't say saul i said sal sol
some people say both sometimes
so it's salvatore it's sal sal the only
person that calls me saul thirty percent
of the time after no one for ten years
is dave attell
and i don't correct them because it's
dave patel
so some night some south some night some
saul
but are you ever sal
saul now because that's almost spanish
like with salt they say like or salima
or salad do you have that jack mercer we
couldn't find it
okay no worries man dude we went on um
thank you we went on your cruise man
yeah and the cruise line just got in
trouble what was that news
you came on cruise one
right it was cruise one
celebrity cruises sued
yeah we got celebrity cruises sued uh
the medics gave hiv infected blood wow
yeah why do they have hiv infected blood
then
you know why do they have that on them
and on the cruise
a celebrity cruise's passenger says her
medical emergency came an absolute
nightmare they gave her blood
transfusion from someone who had hiv
dang that's bad luck
seven day cruise that started december
4th so winter time
[Music]
and she says doctor
diagnosed
gastrointestinal but she started
suffering from rectal bleeding that's
why she went for help
what's going on there what's going on
there suppositories dude i'm telling you
yeah that's how probably
and this could have been one of them
because of some of these cruises man
it's a lot of people out there doing
pills and doing sex yep
uh announcing staff solicited blood from
passengers over the ship's pa system
said they needed type a negative
uh that's my type it is swear
that's my type yeah
you know yours is that song about blood
what is that
um this woman says four passengers
stepped up to donate blood and she got
the transfusion wow
and someone stepped up to give blood
with hiv
like yo what the [ __ ] is that about
like they didn't know either they didn't
know
i mean that's a tough call this whole
thing there's a lot of people at fault
here yeah and sometimes it's like if you
at the if you're i remember when we're
out on a cruise we couldn't even get
fresh milk so it's like you sometimes
you're out there you got to take what
you can get yeah especially if you're
going to die was our cruise your first
cruise that you were ever on
no i went on this thing called semester
at sea it was like a floating school oh
wow that went around the whole world
actually
around the planet you how long was that
it was 100 days
i knew and we i went i was a student i
worked in the book shop
on the boat yeah
how old were you i was 19 years old i
know i was 20 years old so it was like
college yeah it was college
they still do it it's called semester at
sea and you go
and have you spoken about this before
i don't know if i've spoken much about
it i've never heard you really that's a
very
that's a very interesting crazy thing
you did it was crazy bro you know so
where did you go we started in vancouver
canada
and then we finished in florida we went
all the way around the whole world you
go around everywhere and you went to
class had homework yeah and then also
worked like your life was did you dock
yeah we would die how often did you dock
and you were able to five days or three
days or five nights or three nights we
would die okay japan china vietnam
malaysia kenya brazil we went cuba dude
we did it are you serious yeah so let me
ask you a question what was the
breakdown of like how often you had to
do schoolwork like did you did you were
you able to maintain your focus and your
studies too or was it just like come on
now like everybody just like phoned it
in and it was just like caligula on it
no you couldn't phone it in you had to
like it was pretty the the teachers were
pretty harsh okay so you really had to
really do it you know so you really had
to do so you did you went to it was what
was your schedule like was it every day
every day class started i think at 8 00
a.m or 9 a.m i can't remember
every day it would alternate except for
days when you're in port so when you
were in the port you could go do stuff
and travel and do whatever you wanted
you just had to be back when the ship
left or you could use the ship as hotel
and stay at hotel
okay so okay so you would you would also
have the option to go get a hotel off
the ship yeah for the days because i was
about to say how could you live for 100
days and not get little in a little like
cruise room like that
yeah it would be crazy you had a
roommate in there and um wow
it was wow if you don't like your
roommate yeah
you're stuck
how was your roommate oh my roommate was
great dude my roommate was a great guy
ryan thomas you talked to him to this
day
he a few years after the ship he passed
away man he was doing basketball he went
to
some school up in the north california
mountains like that weed school what's
that weed school up there
chino or cheapo cheeto uh
not cheeto it's like
it's like a place where the kids all do
weed and everybody's growing weed and
eating weed people are made out of weed
people have little weed dolls and stuff
voodoo dolls even made out of weed it
sounds fantastic yeah i mean it sounds
like he died of a heart attack because
it was so amazing yeah
so anyway r.i.p brother so anyway he
passed away but um the cruise was it was
an unbelievable experience man i mean it
was just cr you know you were just you
could get two wines a night you got
tickets for wines and they'd have the
bar open you get two wines at night
but we had a guy on there that died bruh
during the cruise yeah this dude died we
were at sea for like 12 days or
something something happened he died and
they put him in the freezer
yeah
man i've heard of that so they put what
are they going to do with them with the
pork loin baby
that's
crazy how he died
huh you know how he died i'm not sure
was that like
did that
were people just like oh [ __ ] somebody
died or were you like oh my god
like they said someone just died a
student died and is in the freezer oh it
was a sec this guy was a senior citizen
oh okay because he had a couple see
about nine seniors on there going to
college on the cruise yes some of them
were like old man that's like it's it
takes somebody to be like i'm gonna go
back to college as an adult is one thing
that's already tough then to be like i'm
gonna go to sea for a hundred days
that's great
so he just died he couldn't hang bro did
they give him an honorary
uh discharge i don't know if we like put
him into the sea like they did with um
osama bin laden i don't know what they
did
i do remember we did a funeral for him
one day
whoa
i remember we did a funeral and people
dressed up and
we put flowers out into the um ocean and
stuff and the crews did a big circle
like that it was like a
oh my god i forgot about that crazy dude
i wish i knew his name mark i think in a
hundred days you could have multiple
relationships like did you have a mini
life within that hundred days yeah like
you got new friends knew this new that
like you know what i'm saying oh yeah
there's people from like different
countries on there
it was crazy bro what made you do that
like was that expensive i'm fascinated
because i never heard of this yeah it's
called semester i see it wasn't that it
was ex uh i it wasn't that expensive man
i mean i worked and save up some money i
had to spend like 6 000 of my own
dollars so yes that was a lot of money
yeah but i worked you know to to do it
and then i got financial aid from my
school so that applied to it okay and
then a friend um the i got a scholarship
from the school okay itself from the
semester at sea wow so i was really
supported you know
i definitely
you know i was grateful that people
helped me oh yeah man what would what
did you major in
i don't remember oh um
urban planning
really oh yeah
that was your major back then
you had the wherewithal back then to be
like i want to get into some urban
planning urban planning dude where are
you going to put that mailbox huh son
right really you want to plant like help
plan cities like infrastructure yeah is
that what that is uh it's more i think
it's like where do the medians go you
know yeah i think i know it is sure if
you have a male if a mailman needs to
come into town what route does he take
to make the least amount of time so it's
effective okay power lines oh traffic
patterns yeah [ __ ] like that grid
patterns yeah yeah a lot of different
planning man some are i guess i'm a i'm
an urban planner you know did you
why did that strike you as interesting
like why did you why did you latch on to
that i think i always used to walk
around a lot of neighborhoods and stuff
so i think i was really kind of
fascinated about that
i liked people's yards
um
i liked looking at what it was like if
people had a yard or didn't have a yard
like what people's lives were like
like rich people have yards you know so
they have like space between them and
like people knowing what they're doing
sure for poor people it's just like
[ __ ] people just don't know what
you're doing
you know what i'm saying like
if your mom rears back to to hit you
hard enough she's gonna [ __ ] a
passing car is gonna hit her on you know
so it's like you can't hide it you know
so i don't know stuff like that kind of
fascinate fascinated me and i always
like love the us postal system when i
was young it's going downhill yeah but
when i was young what'd you major in
finance oh really yeah just because i
didn't know what to do like i had no
idea i started college in 17 and they
asked you to pick a major and i was
literally like i want to make money
finance means money yeah that's
literally how i chose it i was like
finance has to do with money i want to
make money i'll do finance i have a
degree in finance did you have was money
like a big influence with your parents
like make money were your parents
business my parents and my family had no
money and i just was like i want to be
successful it wasn't like i want to be
like rich i just was i just want to make
sure i
make money you know i can support myself
yeah and that was how how simple that
decision was it was like and i don't
mean simple like easy to make i mean
simple like simpleton yeah i was like i
want to make money so i'll check finance
and then i did it
you know i don't know why i took that
yeah i had no interest in him at all wow
yeah you ever see yourself going back of
interest do you ever
of course you don't see yourself going
that's the dumbest question i'm about to
ask you do i ever see you getting like
one of those like kind of like little
advisors
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know man i don't know why i
did that it was a while besides the
people and besides the relationships i
forged college for me was a complete
waste
complete waste i retained none of it it
was it was expensive i got a scholarship
too but did you were you uh a smart kid
what were you were you like a nerdy kid
were you like an athletic kid were you
just kind of like neither i was like
italian i did
i'm half italian are you yeah yeah yeah
i had to italian half cuban and puerto
rican oh wow spanish yeah please
yeah right so no i was good grammar
school was like straight a's high school
was pretty much like low a's but with
not a lot of application so that was
good you just you can't you could do it
and then i just was like fun yeah i
wasn't like a super i played hockey for
for in high school for a little bit but
i wasn't great i played like my i was
like signed up and i played you know
basketball baseball and grammar school
was bad yeah it wasn't good
you know i tell this story about me and
my uh so that our school got a
basketball team for the first year and i
was in seventh grade and if you were in
eighth grade you automatically were on
varsity and then or something like that
and everybody else had to try out
so we tried out i wasn't good you know
but i tried out i was good in like my
neighborhood you know when people came
in and had like skill sets you know i
mean i wasn't good right and so
everybody made varsity and everybody
else who didn't make it automatically
you want to play you could and that was
jv and then the coach for jv we didn't
have one and so my friend's mom
volunteered and she volunteered and she
just was like learning basketball with
us
and then we used to have it was like it
was literally like the like like the
like the molly crew of it could have
been a cartoon it was like all those
castaways on this team
and we used to have these these these
practices and she used to have a
clipboard like the dry erase clipboard
and just be like go this way you know
like
our first game we played 14 games that
year we went owen 14.
our first game uh i was like watch we're
gonna play these kids that are
definitely like these kids are all gonna
be from like urban areas they're gonna
be like sure enough every kid on a team
was six foot and uh we
and they like played basketball black
basketball was life for them as opposed
to us they they beat us 44 nothing
44 nothing dude and then after you'd
line up in the middle of the thing to
kid hands and like then go get a snack
upstairs we used to play at the catholic
huge organization with the cyo yeah so
it's a cyo league so it was all the
catholic schools right so we would say
thank you but at the end of the first
game it was traumatizing dude at the end
of the first game the parents were so
into it on their side yeah right and
they were screaming and yelling and
everything and then at the buzzer
the parents started to chant 44 zip zip
44 zip 44 and they just came down off
the stand they were screaming it and
waving [ __ ] and while we were trying to
shake hands they were getting our face
like 44 zip zip and then we had to go up
the steps together to go to like the the
like common area to have like our capri
suns and we were going up the stairs and
they were screaming it was bellowing in
the hallways and they were screaming at
44 zip zip and i was like damn man it
was traumatizing damn now we scored
points in every other game
but we never got shut out again but we
went on 14 the second game 56 to three
we lost i had the three points you did
yes
and then they still did the we still
were part of the awards dinner
we were part of the awards dinner at the
end of the season
dude
he is the worst part of it i was the
team's mvp
i swear to god i accepted the award i
got up and i took the trophy in front of
everyone you get to at the dinner you've
had to pay to be there i had 16 points
on the season
total total yeah 16 points and i was mvp
praise god is that great but did it give
you some confidence though no really
really really knock my confidence down
just game after game just 14 games of
burying my confidence in the last game
of the season we didn't realize we
something happened with the universe and
we were like landing shots we were
sinking shots and then at the buzzer we
we huddled up and our coach goes
look up and we looked up and we were
winning it was like 14 13 or something
and we went we just looked at each other
like we're winning we're [ __ ] winning
we lost
but it was like that was all like that
was like our big moment like our rudy
moment like at the head look up
yeah
we had no idea we were winning you know
like here's a question right here from a
beautiful young fella right there thank
you brother
hey sal hey theo big time fan of both
you
i just wanted to ask about sal's like
school life we never really heard much
about his child life and i just want to
know what was the worst thing you
probably did in school
damn school life
um
i wasn't bad in school i was the class
clown were you but respectfully oh you
know i was like i was a likeable i
didn't like push
it wasn't never disrespectful right you
wouldn't even do anything mean the joke
i was always there with the joke always
there like to get to laugh no matter
what i said yeah which sounds
stereotypical but that's what it was
like always when we had school functions
on stage i would volunteer i i'd do
impressions of the teachers oh yeah like
you know all that stuff yeah um i used
to love the jefferson's one well the
jefferson's is my favorite show oh yeah
of all time and so it was syndicated
when i was little i used to watch it
with my grandparents i used to live with
them so i love it it just has a place in
my heart so i would memorize the
jefferson's
uh like i would get like a pad and
feverishly write down like the things
they said the things they said
and then i would then i would memorize
that and i would
have an impression i would do george
jefferson and word got out in the
schools so people used to ask me like
third grade they were like the teacher
like all right if everyone's good at the
end sal will get up and do the george
jefferson scenes
so it was like that that was never
disrespectful one time i got in trouble
in high school uh we were sitting on the
steps and this teacher she was a she was
a nutcase dude yeah she was a spanish
teacher her name was mrs degiulio if
she's out there and she's watching and
we know that she is i'm sorry but it's
all going to come out now we if people
know mr giulio and you should yeah and
she was like i think she was a bipolar
yeah uh i didn't know then though they
didn't have it then but i understand now
right without a doubt she was wow
because she'd be nice and then she she
would
flip out on you
and uh but we didn't know what it was so
we just thought like
[ __ ] this lady yeah oh yeah totally but
then then you wanted you wanted to be
nice because when she actually turned it
was like you kind of got nervous because
she she had this look so one time she
was coming down the steps it was in
between between classes and we would
just mind our own business i was sitting
on the steps and she turned to one row
of steps and she was on land to come
down the other and she just freaked and
she went like get up and get out of my
way i'm coming down the stairs no and it
rubbed me the wrong way
i was like 15. i just turned around and
i said okay we're not really doing
anything bad here so why don't you ask
us nicely first yeah and she was like
what did you say and i said ask us
nicely
and then she gave me uh detention and
she wrote it on there in quotes told him
to move out of the way on the steps he
responded quote unquote ask me nicely
which honestly is that really detention
like you screamed at me to get off the
steps so rudely and all i was asking was
common decency and then she put me in
the slammer
you know we had this lady beautiful lady
in r.i.p she did die
her name uh everybody you've spoken
about on this podcast so far has died
really everybody i think i think it's
the fourth person you spoke about that
has died dude i think just the area we
were in it just
breeded you know people were gonna die
i hate to say that
all right i don't know maybe i have
something about death but it's like this
lady's name was um what was her name
she was principal
um
short italian nancy woods was her name
and she was italian 700 italian you know
she was swamp water italian you know
what i'm saying she [ __ ] yeah you
know uh
she had
bay leaves in her calzone you know she
had just a little mix of things going on
and she um
she uh
what are we talking about
you
you
yeah yeah and getting in trouble asked
me nicely she moved she had bipolar
yeah spanish teacher i wonder what miss
woods did
he must have done something i was going
to tell you she died
she did die
yes she died a couple years like a year
ago i think damn
she was cool
um
oh dude we had uh
we had this guy
mr coleman he would sleep in the trunk
of his car at lunch he would go get in
the [ __ ] truck really trunk of his
car and [ __ ] sleep in it like open
yeah open it up get in there he just
didn't mind much that no one saw him it
just was like some weird habit he had or
something you know maybe something of
growing up he used to do or his family
did
but uh
we had another teacher mr lambert he and
he passed we had alcoholism
but he i remember one time i was
cheating on a test in his class and my
cheat sheet fell on the floor and he
walked by and he goes excuse me i
believe he dropped this he didn't even
realize it was a cheat sheet you know
just something
amazing it was absolutely
he like pardoned me yeah pardon me wow
you dropped this buddy [ __ ] he was
cheating school he was the sweetest guy
you all cheated everyone cheated
everybody did
a lot of people cheated off me but i
also cheated too did you yeah people
would just be like when you had teachers
that like that they were like a loot for
whatever you just be like what do you
got what do you got for this what do you
got for that sometimes you get if you
got caught though oh man i remember one
kid got caught got pulled out of the
room and uh there was one point with
this eighth grade teacher his name was
miss dawson she was also a gym teacher
that became an eighth grade teacher and
she was like a thick like short-haired
coke bottle glass like she was a she was
like the the the lesbian back then oh
yeah like she was
and you didn't want to mess with her she
was intimidating like at all times we
had that at all times and everyone
everyone was in line with her luckily
she was gone by the time i got to eighth
grade but she was doing a proctoring and
exam and she got someone and she took
this kid james out of my of our class
then he answered her background and she
grabbed him by the neck and pushed him
against the cinder cinderblock wall like
that
dude no joke damn yeah man teachers used
to get pretty graphic man they used to
get on point they used to let them get
buck a little more that's nuts yeah for
our age my dad
my dad in this uh like
young young grammar school whatever had
a nun
like tell him to put his hands down and
wailed him on the hands with the ruler
right so my grandmother gets a call says
come down to the school your son is
suspended oh and he she says what
happened she gets down to the school she
goes you son of a spider what happened
well the teacher he was misbehaving for
the teachers and put his hands out and
whaled him with the nun a nun a welding
with the ruler he took his metal
lunchbox and slammed her in the face
with it
my father did that got kicked out and
then my grandmother said she deserved
every [ __ ] bit of that wow and she
goes i'm taking him out of the school
you're not suspended i'm taking him out
damn yeah can you imagine
hitting a nun in the face with a metal
lunchbox
but retaliation right you know oh yeah
which like in this day and age if that
happened in school right now the kid
would not even be
you can't in this day and age if that
kid hit her back after she hit him like
that the kid would be a hero yeah
the kid would be a hero
it's crazy how it's all set up now
everything is like um
and it almost doesn't even matter what
people do it's just what is recorded and
then shown yeah that's the even crazier
part yeah um there was so many things
different back then like we didn't know
she had bipolar we didn't know when kids
in the class were autistic like we
didn't know anything it was just like oh
he's just weird you know like he just
he's just a little different or whatever
like but we didn't have these terms no
no everybody was i remember i've gotten
learning disabled for a little while you
know they they put me in there for like
um a little while when i was in third
grade
and back then dude it was you know
everybody was in that [ __ ] you know you
could run too fast you were in there
like right right i'm seeing people in a
wheelchair
autism people with no arms like it was
just like this crazy bunch dude you know
um
i got i got asked if i
a couple of years ago i had a bunch of
people
i got i got a bunch of messages like
telling me about autism
some asking like asking if i have it and
and once out of nowhere i didn't know
like why
like i just like i i i it was like i
just saw a bunch of messages at once
that were about autism i didn't know why
but um i think like i think
it was right after i did an appearance
on uh uh regis uh not regis uh kelly
ripa
and and at the time chris pratt was the
we did that we did press
[Laughter]
we were doing press and we went on the
morning show with kelly ripa chris pratt
was the guest so you know chris pratt
yeah you know him gnome i feel like you
might have for some reason i met he
invited me to be in a film that he did
okay yeah yeah that was oh yeah that was
yeah because i think we were gonna do
the
the cruise again
and you had to do a movie was that oh
yeah that's right yeah that's right i
want to get you back because you were so
sweet on the first cruise oh thanks i
had booked it up completely and you were
like i'll just come on like i'm hanging
everything and yeah it was so sweet man
and then i wanted to and you know i was
trying to get but yeah anyway he's on
and he's in this movie the magnificent
seven that remake of that western movie
at the time it was just came out as a
blockbuster there was like an ensemble
cast of a-list morgan freeman's in it oh
no it was denzel denzel's in it right so
the night before i had cotton really
really really drunk
uh i don't normally do that but like i
just i don't remember what i was waiting
a wedding night oh yeah so i show up i
am hungover with the shakes okay and you
have to get arrived at like 6 50 in the
morning and for the morning show right
so i get there and i'm trembling man
and i don't know what to do and i'm like
i can't go on i said can i please can
you please find an office for me to lay
down in and they did because we weren't
going to be on for an hour they took me
to someone's office i laid down on a
couch in someone's office just shaking
so
i'm watching the
the show on the tv and it's in the feed
right and
then like so so at the beginning they
give away a prize have you ever watched
regis and kathy lee when you were little
but i know about it so every day they
take a phone or they just take a phone
call and someone in the audience and if
the person in the audience answers
correctly like them and the phone person
wins like a trip
or like something big every morning
every day oh wow so they're doing this
trip right so they asked the lady a
question and uh it's easy but she gets
it wrong right and then chris pratt goes
i adamware will give you the trip anyway
it was a vacation and then on air he
goes what what oh i can't do that
because it's like law it's all
game show right right so then he goes oh
i can't and on air he's like oh i don't
know what to do and everyone's like oh
and then he goes uh
i'll give you the trip i'll just buy it
i'll give it to you and everyone's like
ah they went nuts right and uh it was
like so nice and then kelly's like i
won't do that to you like me and you are
gonna split the trip you're still going
and the audience goes crazy right
then denzel washington comes out next
and he's in the movie magnificent
magnificent seven with him and he comes
out and
the first thing he says was uh he goes i
just i was watching on the feed he goes
uh what happened how much was the trip
and chris pratt goes like 5700 and he
goes
three ways i'm gonna go three ways with
you on the trip so everyone goes nuts
right so i'm laying that you know how
you always need stories on these things
yeah they want you to have stories so
i'm laying there like half sick and i'm
like all right i got an idea so i'm i i
have this thing i'm going to do in my
head and then i'm like i want to do
something else these things never go
well morning shows they like rush you
through you never really get to really
make jokes you know so i was like [ __ ]
it so i had our assistant go to the
store get a pack of hanes t-shirts white
hanes undershirts and a marker
and i wrote i
in my own handwriting i wrote
magnificent seven on on the detains
t-shirt and i put that on
except for fun i spelt it wrong i wrote
magnificant savon uh-huh s-e-v-a-n and
magnificant so maybe we can't savon so i
was like i'll just i'll go out there
and i'll go out there and what i'll do
is they'll immediately see my shirt and
be like oh what is that you know and
i'll be like oh i just thought that you
and denzel needed help promoting the
movie obviously they don't need help
right i'm like yeah so i just want to
support and help you guys any way i can
i know you need to help and then i
thought they would pick on how i
misspelled it and it would be a nice
joke so i put on the shirt
so we're behind the thing we're ready to
go out there i'm wearing this hanes
t-shirt that has marker on it says
magnificant savannah and they call us
out and we go on people are cheering i'm
waving right and we go to sit down and
right before we sit down the audience
stops clapping and i go i just won't let
everybody here know just off the top i'm
not going four ways on the trip with a
woman
right i thought i would get a laugh
but they took me seriously it just
bombed and then kelly goes no no it's
okay we're covering it it's okay and i
was like well that was a joke yo then i
sat down to the interview and nobody
mentioned the shirt dude
nobody mentioned the shirt so i
and then after that i just started
getting autistic messages because i just
went like i went on like i came out i
was like i'm not paying i'm not paying
for the for the trip and then i sat down
and my shirt was handmade and misspelled
and nobody mentioned it and then that
that everyone was like yo like they're
just sending me links
on autism
people like hey can you come speak at
our school
dude
that's bananas it's online too it's
online like you can pull it up
damn bro that's bananas man
i'm trying to think if i had like a real
good thing like that where i went on to
a talk show
you you do you like talk shows do you do
when you do them because i always feel
like they do local news a lot yeah no
i'm good i i just i'm good i used to do
lo oh i used to do local news a lot so
yeah yeah right right from when you're
going to town yeah but i never did i'm
trying to think if i did i never did
like any panels like
a lot of comedians like once a lot of
guys quit going like the tonight show
and stuff like that you didn't really do
that much of that type of thing yeah
um
they always just want you to i got one
coming up i'm doing i guess seth meyers
and every time i go on i just feel like
it just feels so canned yeah because
they ask you to they pre-interview right
but
yeah it's just a different experience
i'm sure yeah um
but i was just gonna accept right but is
he yeah he makes it easy yeah that's
cool he's nice yeah
yeah i'm trying to think of um there was
something i was gonna tell you about
oh you guys have so with y'all show uh
within practical jokers you didn't even
talk anything about it you guys have um
[Music]
joe is not gonna be on the show anymore
yeah wow for now i guess right yeah
um would did they ever did they try and
think about bringing somebody else in
well they asked us what we wanted to do
and we just thought about like a hundred
different permutations for and just
landed on the fact that we didn't want
to replace him yeah because that person
would be
already shot you know like you kid's
hard to replace him so we just were like
let's just uh right now we're bringing
in a guest each episode to just help out
with the like the punishment but it's
like people that we know that were
really psyched and interested to get on
uh you know so we've had like eric andre
method man uh jillian bell uh rob riggle
david cross
like all these like really cool guests
you know um and like we're booking you
know just and this we just uh
we finished season nine the last nine
episodes that we started before the
pandemic so those start airing and uh i
don't know when this comes out but
those start airing june 16th okay and
then in two weeks we've been writing
season ten and in two weeks we start
filming season ten and we'll do uh for
the first time might we shorten the
episodes and we're going to do 18
because i want to kind of have six
months on six months off to do comedy
and stuff so we're doing 18 episodes
we've got 18 guests but then
check this out uh they're just in the in
the in there is punishment and we do a
cold open with them and a couple of
interstitials so they're like threaded
through the episode okay so they're like
anchored as the guest but in the middle
bits when we need four
we made it so that we can bring anybody
we want at all anyway so the idea at
first was like oh look we could bring
anyone like from a comedian friend to
our family to literally like the thing
was we said the halal guy outside our
office yeah and we started doing that
like i brought my barber on you know we
brought like it just so because it's
like just a mixed bag you know yeah so
yeah so we did that and it's been fun
you know it's just a different energy
and stuff you know yeah so it's been
good so we started filming that in a
couple weeks wow yeah is it hard to stay
motivated with it as things get keep
going that much is it hard to like
not that you don't care about it but is
it what have you learned about that has
that been interesting yeah i mean you
know the motivation's there you know
because it's it's our reputation and the
show's been on so long and you know i'm
never gonna i'm not gonna half-ass it
you know yeah
but um
we said we would do the show until we
like stopped having fun but it's just so
much fun yeah you know and and you know
our crew is another 40 50 people that
you don't see well we put them on a lot
now we put our crew on but like so it's
not just us us having fun like our we've
been with these people some of them for
10 years
so it's like this family you know so we
still have fun man we you know the the
pandemic made us have to rethink how we
did everything so we did a whole season
in a pandemic when we couldn't even go
up to anybody so that was fun because we
have to we're always trying to push and
change and evolve it and stuff like that
so you know so it's it's always a little
different each season like we don't just
go back and do the same bits we did like
when people describe the show they go
these you know these friends they put an
earpiece now to do and say what they're
told and if not you get punished that's
the most simple way to explain the show
it is yeah and it is like a third of the
show yeah and it was a lot of the show
when we first started but in the first
season or two but really if you watch
the show
that is just one element of it there's
so much we create so many scenarios and
games and situations and like that
aren't even beholden to doing and saying
what you're told right right it's just
like that's the easiest way to that's
the elevator pitch right like so but
yeah we so we we you know we have fun
like like figuring all those things out
yeah yeah are you worried about not
having joe on there
you know i was because he's just he's
one of a kind he's one of a kind he's
the funniest dude in the world and
and then like but it's like you have a
recipe that's working
and then you and if you remove a main
ingredient so i we didn't know what to
expect you know but you know because the
nature of the show whereas like we we
we are out there like we're always
switching who we're doing it with so
nothing felt foreign because i've been
out there mur just me and him i've been
out there with you just mean i've been
out there alone just me
so in that respect it didn't feel like
completely foreign um and then
you know and then we were so focused on
getting the new formula to work and then
getting this energy from these people
that came on as guests
that like you know that kind of like
filled like a little bit of like what
would be and you know it took like it's
like when you get on stage you know we
got there you know we started to film
and we're like alright let's see how
this is going to be like i don't know if
it's going to be you know gloomy of
course we miss him you know yeah but
then you know you start laughing and
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm laughing i'm
laughing this is i had fun today right
and then you're like all right all right
we're still laughing what's having fun
you know um
that's the barometer i think and that's
always been the barometer i think with
you guys as group it seems like
i mean i remember the first time i ever
hung out with you guys was at in
nashville at like the wild west comedy
fest this is years ago yeah man and i
could 2014 is when i met you i think
yeah i couldn't believe how much fun it
was
at the festival
yeah and just being around you got like
it was ridiculous and then joe is so
crazy and then afterwards they're like
he doesn't even drink i'm like oh
he thought he what
drinking his own blood
he'd be on a bar with his shirt off he
doesn't drink he doesn't do drugs he
doesn't do anything it just blew my mind
as to how much fun could be had by a
group um
yeah i think that's what it's always
been for a lot of people um let me text
my therapist real quick yeah babe then
i'm gonna be late and then what time you
gotta roll out at uh probably i got a 12
30 but it's only like 15 away so maybe
like seven eight minutes ten minutes
yeah okay cool
zoom yeah i got my life it's been
helpful to zoom yeah with therapy yeah i
used to have to go into the city to do
it you didn't just do it on zoom yeah
yeah i think once i got comfortable
enough with the therapist you know i'm
going twice a week right now and going
to a lot of meetings so good man yeah
i'm dude this is like
even just being able to sit here and
laugh with you it's been like it's been
so hard for over the past few years i
could imagine bro i don't know what
happened it just something happened and
it wasn't you got a good support system
around you now now it's working better
you know i didn't real i think i was
trying other things than like um maybe
my recovery program to make me feel
better and it wasn't help you know it
just wasn't working out
so i'm trying to lean back into that you
look good bro thanks man you do i feel
pretty healthy you look good man thank
you i'm the worst shape of my life but i
appreciate it oh yeah yeah really yeah i
gotta turn it around now i gotta turn it
around why yeah i cuz i need to okay
that's too much i filmed my first
special in january too you are going to
lose like 50 pounds yeah wow i mean i
haven't started yet but right
it's around the corner
but do you feel different being like why
do you want to be like fit or what do
you have i don't want to feel like i
feel now oh you feel bad well i no but
like i don't know i'm you know it's just
it's just like anything right when
you're like i i'm i'm someone who's
fluctuated in weight my whole life up
and down 50 every few years i go from
like two to fifteen to two to fifty two
to fifty for like the last 15 years
that's cool so it's just like when i
know when i hit 250 i gotta get back
down to two oh okay you know there's a
journey there and i stay there for a
while and i slowly go back up and back
down it's like one of those carnival
games kind of yeah everything with you
kind of has like a little bit of a game
i know you probably know this and people
say this stuff but you know we go back a
while you you know you know me in my
personal life too and i'm just like if
you ever like
you call me anytime man yeah thank you
for anything like that anything just a
vent to bounce [ __ ] off of whatever you
know i know that i'm not like i'm on the
east coast but like dude i you know
thank you yeah
thanks man yeah i think sometimes i got
in this negative place where i felt just
like really isolated and i was isolating
myself so it was like i was creating my
own a lot of my own problems and
you know i just didn't realize it though
like um
but it's all you know it's something
that's just life it's like you know my
life got super busy you know it's like
you don't know what happens when your
life gets busy and when things change
for you like i remember one time we were
at some party and you had tried to not
have a manager for a while and you're
like finally i have to have a man i have
to have help yeah yeah you know we
didn't have we don't have one for years
couple years i remember just like it was
a tipping point
and it was like we were holding out you
know because you hear that agents will
say yeah you don't need a management
manager say you don't an agent or even
today people like [ __ ] man you know why
are you giving all that away a lot of
our boys don't have managers yeah i
don't have one now yeah but and but i
remember just you saying that oh we have
to get i i got to a year like i got to a
point where i needed to get some yeah
yeah yeah i think like you know with the
tv and stuff you kind of need someone to
fight those battles and navigate that
for you yeah if it was just like just
solely just doing stand-up the way to
everyone's diy these days and building
their own audiences and stuff i think
now like it's shifting what you would
need but i'm with my team for so long
now they're like family you know so yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah if you have television
and stuff involved i do think it gets
different yeah we had a couple questions
that came in i wanted to get to one or
two of them real quick from some uh
listeners man
um
theo i love the podcast so much what's
up sal loving practical jokers my name
is ezra ezra and basically i'm just
asking you sal um have you ever got
swung on in practical jokers
sure people asked that a lot huh yeah um
yeah i almost did look after 10 years
not a lot yeah because we're not really
trying to we're not really trying to
piss people off yeah we're more just
trying to like
be muse bewilder confused like whatever
just you know it's more like that it's
more on us but everyone's while you're
gonna come across a person yeah that
already is like that in their normal
life and it's just looking for something
yeah so we've all all of us have been a
couple times each in situations one time
i was at the car show at the jacob
javits center and i was working for fiat
that was what i was doing and uh they
kept this guy and this girl walked up
and they kept saying like just shadow
the girl like if she turns like don't
ever like stay behind her so she pivoted
and i went behind her it was like the
first second i did it and he literally
pushed her out of the way grabbed me and
put his fist back he said what are you
doing what are you doing right now and
her boyfriend yeah he's a big dude he
looked like he did like ufc and [ __ ]
yeah he like he was ripped yeah but he
went from zero to he literally pushed
her out of the way put his fist up
in in in a half a second all i did and
he's like go ahead go ahead he goes what
are you doing what are you doing and i
was in like a suit jacket and tie i was
like showing the fiat yeah and i looked
at him
and he he literally you know you know
you know there's a difference between
like go ahead bro he was like you saw
like
like he was like that and i just i
didn't want to like antagonize it
anymore you know defuse oh yeah so i
just looked at him and he goes what are
you doing what do you do and i go
i'm just trying to get you guys into a
fiat you know
and i just stayed the course and he's
like yeah what do you don't don't [ __ ]
with me he's like don't you guys
i just i don't know what you mean man he
goes i'm just i'm just trying to show
you guys this fiat
like just soft like that you know and
then like they took him away and then
they you know and then he didn't want to
hear nothing but uh murray got slapped
in the face hard with a guy's cell phone
like he went like that like popped him
in the face
but this guy was crazy though this guy
we were filming at like a odd lot like
an odd job store like you know what that
is oh yeah they got the rules
like yeah yeah yeah it'll like have like
half of an autumn and you're like
yeah like and truly and like cereal and
like all that [ __ ] right oh yeah they
got like rescue milk yes
so this guy
is is on his phone and he's a big dude
man he was like six five huge dude
and
murray uh is
the guy's talking and they have bins and
i guess the guy's standing and the bin
in front of murray has bronze and like
this bin might have no pads you know but
so murray like as he's on the phone i
would like murray takes out the bra and
he like he's like he puts it up against
the guy to like just see and he's like
you're my wife's size and then he puts
up the guy and the guy just whipped him
out and he goes he goes what are you
[ __ ] doing and then the guy i guess
was having a bad day and he just looked
at murray and started to go at him and
then murray ran and he started chasing
murray charging at him screaming
charging at him and swinging at him and
murray's running around the aisles and
the guy's chasing full public
the restaurant's open the store is open
and then he swung at him and he
clipped off right here right and then
everyone was like all right and then
they asked him to leave and the guy went
out and goes i'm gonna he goes i'm gonna
come back here because i'm leaving i'm
gonna come back here i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill everybody
we had to shut it down immediately
because we didn't know if that was a
true threat yeah he was screaming i'm
going to come back here i'm going to
kill you guys i'm coming back and we're
like all right let's just let's just cut
this out right now
for the bras huh yeah but but but but
that's really uncommon oh yeah that dude
i used to hide this isn't like
it's not like your game show but it's
like i remember hiding at my buddy's
house in his hamper and smelling his
[ __ ] mom's bra
when i was a kid man
oh [ __ ]
yeah what are you gonna do kids
what'd it smell like ah smelled like
[ __ ] did it smell like like perfume
or did it smell like ham yeah it's not
like perfume i think it just smelled
like a home kind of you know yeah it was
like sir you know looking for i wasn't
really looking exactly he didn't know
you did that no he still doesn't know
yeah and i would never tell him if he
were on his deathbed or something like
that i would tell him
or physically he might be if he knows
you yeah
that's [ __ ] hilarious well let's got
one more question maybe that came
through man i gotta go to therapy dude
damn morning sale or good afternoon theo
good afternoon sal
um today's i've got a question
and it's what's the poorest thing you've
done
for example mine was
uh i used to wash my car
at the petrol station with the little um
windscreen wiper get around my whole car
in the grease everything's pretty good
car wash
so yeah what's the poorest thing you've
ever done hey babe
i've done a lot of poor things yeah yeah
i've used before yeah i mean i didn't
come from any money yeah but i was
growing up i got to think about it like
i i mean i did poor stuff one thing i
did i don't know if it's the poorest
thing i've done but one thing when i was
older and i started working out of
college i was working at prudential
securities
and they had a cafeteria
and what i would do is and i someone
told me this and i did it but i was i
used to do it all the time but i i was
sweating every time i did it
what i would do is i would go get a
large dixie cup and cap for a fountain
soda okay but then i would go to the
chicken tenders station and i would
stuff the dixie cup with like six seven
chicken tenders put it on put the straw
and go and pay like a dollar nineteen
for the cup instead of seven dollars for
the tenders
yeah that was like when i was like a
nine to five like i was like i had a
desk and everything yeah and i would go
and steal those chicken fingers at like
every other day man and i was always
when i got on the line to pay like i was
always so nervous that they were gonna
like is it because it really is that's
really a really a bad look yeah get
caught with that you know you call yeah
with a cup of chicken tender you're like
i thought it was yes
okay but it was like you know i'm trying
to save money man yeah that's a good i
was making no money you know like my
salary at this high school out of
college was 28 000 a year wow yeah yeah
you're cutting corners then man i
remember one time we had a um rental
car and we got an accident it got a dent
in it right
and we tried to get uh
we got like some we uh caught some bird
right pigeons and got him with [ __ ] over
the dent like over the dent you haven't
so that it would uh
hide the
thing yeah
in florida
yeah i guess they [ __ ] enough that like
it's it might happen oh you could make
it look for sure i mean we [ __ ] up half
the whole like you know one quarter pi
watch you just held a pigeon yeah oh i
can't hold foul really no oh wow they
tried to make me gr uh commandeer a
chicken on the show and it was [ __ ] and
everywhere but that that's they're too
wiry they're too
they're too like i don't know birds you
know i don't mind them in the air but
yeah i don't like handling them they put
a hawk on my wrist once i [ __ ] myself
you couldn't handle it
joe used to have a parrot that would
attack me of course he did yeah wonder
what that's about
the parrot just the whole thing that you
can't you don't like that foul on you
well no the hawk was the hawk is scary
as [ __ ] yeah but uh i don't know just a
while i mean maybe you can get something
you can get used to but that was the
first time i was ever handling a chicken
oh yeah you know you just you don't know
like you know like
yeah when chickens are very volatile
yeah you know i think it's um
they deserve to be an entree that's what
i think really i think when i see some
of the meats on andre liston i'm like ah
this [ __ ] don't deserve to make
it up here we know why he got here yeah
chicken if chicken's in there i'm like
these [ __ ] deserve it because they're
they're pretty gangster man yeah um we
had a turkey farmer on in the turtle
yeah though once one of them dies
they'll freaking you know they'll go at
that one it's very um you know it's a
uh
like i don't know what that movie is
called um
gangs in new york
you know they get very uh territorial
yeah they'll [ __ ] second year out
it's year out wow you know they don't
play okay
well dude we didn't get to talk really
about the crews that i came on with you
let's talk about it next time anytime
dude i'd love to this was so much fun
dude i've never done it i don't think
i've ever done this with you i don't
think so
yeah right on i'm glad you uh dude thank
you so much for coming come on come on
if you're ever in new york come on i got
i do a podcast called hey babe oh yeah
yeah and uh one called taste buds with
joe derosa if you know joe
oh yeah yeah i know joe too we do a
podcast little taste buds so we got the
two uh come on either of any time
tastebuds were just arguing over foods
really it's fun it's just like we just
literally get into real big arguments oh
wow over just like food and then me and
chris is just you know just bullshitting
and stuff yeah yeah man i love him uh
anytime we'd love to have you on dude
yeah especially now that i'm starting to
feel a bit better i think it'll be
easier for me to go do them you know
it's been hard for me to go be a guest
just because also you when you got your
own podcast it's hard oh hell yeah yeah
but especially new york was kind of
close so i got to get up there and see
you guys yeah i never do this when i'm
out here there's this whole trip uh
because i came i'm touring so i came
through on tour and uh
i was like i'm just gonna do all my
friends part you know just do
everybody's podcast which i never get to
do it so it's been a fun week man that's
cool man yeah well thanks for making us
one of them man i appreciate it yeah of
course of course uh in the new season
when does it come up june 16th it starts
on thursday nights and uh i'm touring i
have like 20 30 cities up right now and
i'm adding all the time on my website
savilecanocomedy.com vegas is one that i
just announced that i'm excited about to
get going but yeah there's tons of
cities up there man we're doing phoenix
and boulder and vancouver seattle
portland evansville louisville dang um
everywhere now you guys are rocking
syracuse just in nashville uh
minneapolis milwaukee i mean it's loaded
up i've been loading up cool you guys
can check it out and go check out sal in
person man um
any way you get sal volcano is a great
way to get him and uh and i'm grateful
that i've got to spend time with you man
thanks so much dude yeah love you buddy
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on
me i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
[Music]
they just